tại vì nè.
Để bài cho ít là sổ thức khát không thôi, bạn sẽ tí quen giới là lóc của ý bình phương nó mằng hai đàn lóc ở chỉ là đối,
ít là sổ thức thì chỉ có chuyện định mình dương có có thể ăn mà,
nó bạn có thể bị đúng nữa,
ăn 2 lò thì đẹp năm đúng,
thì em chưa đến tắm mới vẫn chắm thì điện đúng như này của mình không.
Tố sâu hành, có hoàn nhiều số phức tiếp,
thỏ mạng được cái zet,
có vời cảm ơn một dễ thì mọi người toàn khác,
dễ số bạn làm sai của tôi không nhiều.
Cái em thế là zet của chúng ta bằng một chíc tiên một dù,
thì một đủ rất là một số thức, nên rất là một số thức và lếu mà rất là một thức.
thì một đúng rất là một rất.
Nhi rất là một đủ rất, nếu mà rất là một lýng số này mà không.